للمزيد حول الموضوع ينضموا الينا من
اسطنبول طه عوده اوغلو الكاتب والباحث
السياسي اهلا بك سيد اوغلو تركيا لعبت
دورا في التوصل الى اتفاقيه تصدير الحبوب
الامن يبدو ان الامور متوتره الان من
الواضح جدا ان روسيا تدفع قدما بالكثير من
المطالب قبيله موعد الثامن عشر من ايار
مايو المقبل
نعم تحياتي لك في البدايه للساده
المشاهدين وهذا ما بدا واضحا من خلال
تمديد روسيا قبل فتره الاتفاق الى 60 يوما
على العكس كما اتفاق عليه في المره الاولى
120 يوما انقره نعم هي حاليا في وضع صعب
لماذا هي احرزت اختراق كبير في هذه الازمه
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وخاصه بتعلق
بازمه الحبوب هناك تستوات اتصالات تركيه
خلال الساعات الاخيره والايام الاخيره
الماضيه ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا فيما
يتعلق بهذا الموضوع وهذه الصفقه ايضا
روسيا هناك مطالب روسيه وتابعنا بالامس
تصريحات والناطق باسم الخارجيه الروسيه
تحدثت عن عقبات ومشاكل واعتقد ان انقره هي
نوعا ما يعني تحاول قدر الامكان اقناع
الجانب الروسي خاصه كما تعلمين يعني ان
روسيا حاليا هي في عزله الدوليه بسبب ان
الضغوط الاوروبيه والامريكيه عليها لذا هي
تعتبر انقره او نافذه لها للعالم ومن هذا
المنطلق انقره تضغط في هذا الاطار لعده
اسباب السبب الاول بان هذه الصفقه هي
مفيده اقتصاديا واستراتيجيه بالنسبه
للجانب التركي وخاصه للرئيس اردوغان
المقبل بعد اسابيع قليله على انتخابات
برلمانيه رئاسيه حاسمه للغايه ايضا هي
مهمه ايضا بالنسبه للمجتمع الدولي للعالم
خاصه يعني اي عقبه وتعطل هذه الصفقه سواء
ممكن تثير ازمه غذائيه في العالم هو بغنى
عنها في الوقت الراهن في الظل الازمات
الاقتصاديه التي موجوده في العالم
من الواضح ان العد العكسي بدا قبل اسابيع
من موعد
التجديد المفترض وهو تجديد ليس يعني في
حكم التحصيل الحاصل ما هي الاوراق التي
تملكها انقره خصوصا لجهت العقوبات
المفروضه على روسيا
والمطالبات الروسيه بتخفيفها في مخص
الاسمده
يعني تستطيع ان تضغط في الوقت الراهن على
روسيا لماذا لان انقره كما اشرت لك حاليا
في وضع حساس جدا مقبل على انتخابات بعد
اسابيع قليله لا تريد ان تغضب روسيا
بالدرجه الاولى وايضا لا تريد يعني ان
تحدث هناك خطا او فجوه في علاقاتها مع دول
الناتو الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
وجه الخصوص يعني هذه نقطه اساسيه متعلقه
بالداخل التركي ولكن انقره سوف تستمر في
دبلوماسيتها استخدام الدبلوماسيه
لايجاد هناك صيغه او حل وسط لهذه المشكله
كما نجحت في السابق في التمديد يعني انقره
هي تقول يجب ان تكون هناك اشعار اخر يعني
هذا الاتفاق ولكن 120 يوم ممكن يتم تمديده
اذا ضغطت انقره على روسيا وايضا متعلق
الام التصوري بالتطورات الميدانيه على
الارض الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه شعرت
روسيا انها هي في وضع صعب ممكن يعني ان
تتفاهم مع انقره وخاصه
التي تعتبر انقره هي نافذه لها على العالم
تستطيع ان تتحرك وان تتحاور عبر انقره
شكرا
الباحث في العلوم السياسيه طه عوده اوغلوه
كنت معنا من اسطنبول